and any of the proceeds from this of
course would benefit the best of all mr.
Davis will be reading and talking about
his new book for half an hour or so and
he wanted to make sure that there would
be plenty of time to answer questions
like most authors I know myself included
he prefers the question-and-answer
session to any kind of even reading his
own words this is appropriate in his
case because his books are an informal
question-and-answer format which allows
them to range all over the map most of
you are probably familiar with the
series but if not this is a good
introduction probably most of you have
at least run across I've heard about
them because the series has been doing
well for about a decade now and we can't
don't know much about history which mr.
Davis informs me is about to be
reprinted including a lot of the things
that you think wouldn't change in
history but you discover new things all
the time like the new Ford at Jamestown
is one of the things he mentioned to me
on the phone the series continues with
very popular books on geography the
Civil War and my favorite a big fat
wonderful book called don't know much
about the Bible which was just a little
too much fun for a few people but most
people are thrilled with it and I think
it's a wonderful introduction to the
whole topic of it the historical
background and the cultural history of
the Bible I write about history and
science and culture myself and one of
the things I wanted to say in this
introduction is that it is not as easy
as mr. Davis makes it look his books are
easygoing informal chatty frequently
very amusing and most important for this
kind of explanatory writing always lucid
and very very clear although they're
packed with information that will
interest people who already know a topic
most of the time they're also the
perfect introduction for people who know
nothing about literally don't know much
about geography or history or anything
else they work best if you follow them
from page one and explore the whole
structure that he's given but they also
being in the question/answer format are
the perfect browsers record after
mentioned one of the fun things in there
he sets the tone for the whole new
with a cartoon from The New Yorker it
shows that TV news talking-head
declaring scientists confirmed today
that everything we know about the
universe is wrong any wrong wrong this
sort of sets the tone for the entire
book it's a lot of fun this formats why
there are four new books in an off suit
offshoot series for children two for
picture books for younger readers and
two for middle grade
mr. Davis told me that he thinks of
himself as such an average person a nice
little modest understatement that he
simply assumes other people will be
fascinated by the same things that pique
his own curiosity
apparently he's correct on this quick
visit to Nashville he's pausing just
long enough to talk about don't know
much about the universe
please welcome Kenneth Davis
good morning and thank you for all all
for being here since leaving our homes
is now an act of patriotism it seems and
I'm happy to see you all here it
certainly is a strange book tour that
I've been on for the past month not like
any book tour I've ever been on before
and people keep saying to me getting
back to normal well I can assure them
that there is no more normal there's
before September 11th and after
September 11th but I am delighted to be
here having heard for many years about
the Nashville the southern festival of
books and I'm delighted to be here so
thank you very much for coming
needless to say this probably isn't the
same speech I would have given a month
ago so much has changed our thoughts are
elsewhere in fact it's kind of hard to
think about space a little bit but I
actually think there are some good
reasons to be thinking about space and
the universe and where people have come
in the last four or five thousand years
from the time they started looking at
the Stars but I want to start first by
actually saying my idea of a speech is
to be brief and to be funny
I can always handle the brief the funny
is a little bit more challenging and I
do hope at the end of it we'll have
plenty of time to ask
and I hope answer some questions my book
as Michael said my books are a series of
questions some of them are occasionally
offbeat and irreverent and quirky and
you probably haven't opened too many
science books that asked if aliens built
the pyramids or if Wernher von Braun was
a war criminal but those are the kinds
of questions I asked because they're the
kind of curiosities I have but to the
point of being grief as a student of
American history I'm always reminded of
an incident in our past there was a
famous speaker Edward Everett he was a
very famous legislator of his day
in 19th century is a famous as a speaker
he was the head of Harvard he was
considered a candidate for president and
they asked him to speak one day and he
gave this long
flowery extraordinary address that was
praised across the country it was three
hours long the same day in the same
place Abraham Lincoln gave up an address
for two and a half minutes which
Gettysburg Address do we remember I
think that's a useful point for all
speakers whether priests or politicians
or poets brevity can be useful now as to
the being funny part I always try to
cover my bases by if I don't talk about
something funny that I might have said
at least talk about something funny that
somebody else said and I was reminded
the other day of a great story from the
inimitable Dorothy Parker she of the
Algonquin wits the extraordinary
collection of writers and poets who
would sit around the Algonquin Hotel and
drink scotch and offer up witticisms
well they had a challenge who could use
a word in a particular word in a
sentence and Miss Parker was given the
word horticulture I don't know how long
she pondered it but she then replied
well you can lead a horse to culture but
you can't make her think so that's the
funny if nothing else now I do talk
about questions a great deal in my books
they as I said there's a series of
questions that's the way don't know much
about history start and I've continued
to use the format through all of my
books and when I was a teenager I used
to pose questions like this mom can I
borrow five bucks for a movie or mrs.
Brown can I get an extension on that
term paper or the real big question will
I ever get a date what Albert Einstein
was a teenager he asked what would the
world look like if I rode on a beam of
light now I don't know why Einstein's
extraordinary query never occurred to me
back in high school maybe it did for
some of you but it certainly didn't for
me but looking back at that and thinking
about it thirty years later
and still scratching in my head over
what he could possibly have men I'm
struck by the fact that none of my
science teachers ever asked that either
they didn't seem to put a lot of
emphasis on big questions like that in
fact my science classes tended to be
long and tedious they didn't inspire
much curiosity about the laws of nature
and the workings of the universe in fact
for me
like many red-blooded American boys
science was less than compelling except
for biology and the intense crush I had
on my teacher I can now confess it there
she was talking about zygotes and
fertilization and chromosomes and the
problem was I couldn't take my eyes off
her as she sat on the edge of her desk
so with that as a distraction in
addition to my being sort of challenged
as a science student I barely managed to
squeak through my year of freshman
biology but as I look back even before
high school to the hole some of my
scientific education before high school
I realized the whole thing was equally
forgettable Anatomy to zoology all I can
remember is endlessly dry deadly dull
classroom hours and I have some vague
recollections of having to draw bad
diagrams of eyeballs and eardrums and
being forced to memorize the periodic
table of elements now people always say
to me you know you always start your
books out with one of these stories
about when you were a kid you did this
or that I talked about in the Bible I
talked about looking out and a church
was being built and was being built in a
shape of an ark and I was more
interested in that and I said are those
true stories and I said absolutely those
things all happen and to prove that I
once had to draw bad diagrams of
eyeballs and eardrums I actually found
the evidence these are my sixth-grade
drawings now my mother bless her saved
all my schoolwork and I just found these
and so there they are that's the proof I
really did draw bad diagrams of eyeballs
and eardrums when I was in the sixth
grade needless to say this is the point
of all this is that we are as a nation
when it comes to science as is true I've
learned of history geography the Bible
we are sadly in the dark on when it
comes to most of these these questions
that's not only sad it's dangerous
particularly in these times I think we
are understanding now more than ever
that having a concept of what the past
is and how the past relates to us today
knowing where places are before we start
sending troops in to hit the beaches is
a pretty good idea so I think the
concept of educating not just our
children but ourselves about the past
about the world around us is not just
something that helps us get through the
next round of Jeopardy or you know Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire it's important
and that's why I think that education
doesn't stop when we get that diploma in
fact I think education is wasted on the
young for the most part it's a lot more
interesting it seems to me to learn a
lot of things when you're a 30 and 40
and 50 and 60 then they seemed when you
were 18 or 12 for that matter but what
makes the shortcoming about space so
remarkable to me at least is that all of
this was happening because I grew up in
the the era of Sputnik and the space
race all this was happening in this
remarkable time in our history I was
born in 1954 three years before the
Soviet Union launched that extraordinary
little satellite named Sputnik which
means traveller in Russian and should
interject here might be interesting for
those of you who remember what happened
when Sputnik was launched 44 years ago
it was a day of panic and fear around
the world here was this basketball-sized
first man-made missile circling the
earth every 90 minutes or so sending
back this little beep beep beep sound
that was tracked all over the world by
shortwave radios there was a moment of
fear and panic in this country that was
like a Pearl Harbor
and a lot of us don't remember that now
either were too young or we forgotten it
it's sort of in the distant fate of
distant recesses that isn't fogs of
history but that moment when Sputnik
went up we all sudden realized the
Soviets had the bomb they also had a way
to get it here it was the era of fallout
shelters it was the era of
duck-and-cover drills
I certainly had to go through them in my
school back in suburban New York it was
the era of sending billions of dollars
of federal aid to American schools for
the very first time in our history it
was the era in which learning calculus
was a patriotic act all of a sudden and
there are people who recall from that
time if they wanted to be in the arts if
they wanted to study a musical
instrument
they're often told well that's
unpatriotic I think it's important to
remember that Sputnik moment and the
fear and the panic that gripped the
country for two reasons first of all if
anyone had suggested to you in 1957 or
1967 for that matter that 30 years later
Russians and Americans would be living
and working together on a space station
and doing it as part of a 16 nation
consortium it would have been laughed at
it would have been considered
implausible it would have been the
workings of some science fiction writer
like arthur c clarke as it certainly was
but here we are in 2001 that memorable
year from science fiction and indeed
soviet former soviet cosmonauts and
russian and american astronauts are
living and working together in space i
don't know about you but that gives me
reason for hope and some cause for
optimism the other thing about the
Sputnik incident it seems to me and
certainly i discuss all of the aspects
of the space program in don't know much
about the universe was it was one more
of those moments when america seemed to
be completely back on its heels
completely unprepared
for what it was facing and we've had
other moments like that on our history
and I feel like we're facing one now so
if there's perhaps a lesson that I that
we can take from the space program from
the history of what we've done from
American history itself is that we do
have an uncanny ability as a nation to
take these knock-down punch moments and
dust ourselves off and pick ourselves up
and get going again in the case of
Sputnik it meant the beginning of the
space program which only 12 years later
it's an astonishing idea that we had
really no space program to speak of and
12 years later after that moment we had
a man on the moon I know some people
wonder about that man on the moon
there's a notorious documentary that
says it was all a NASA publicity event
and we can certainly discuss that at
some point but indeed we did put a man
on the moon 12 years after Sputnik
that's an extraordinary tribute to what
technology coming together with the
human desire to reach out to explore to
find what is out there what's over the
next hill that's the story of geography
that's the story of don't know much
about the universe why the and that's
why this book is about so much more than
just what is a black hole and how far
away from the Sun but uh I want to go
back if I made to that idea of this
problem with education especially
science education because it's not just
science and it's not just history it's a
whole range of subjects science it seems
to me has even gotten a shorter shrift
again surprisingly since as I said I
grew up in that period when we were
spending billions of dollars on the
space program but somehow it never
translated into our classes in fact
about the only thing I can remember from
junior high school or high school that
had to do with learning about science or
learning about the universe and
astronomy was taking a field trip to go
see 2001 a Space Odyssey when it came
out and I can assure you that my
teachers were as bit
as we were by what we had seen on that
seventh grade field trip they didn't
have any answers for us either it's it's
astonishing to think that 2001 when that
film came out I guess in around 1967 or
so 2001 seemed so so far away yet here
we are
but we also a usually used to take the
occasional trip to the American Museum
of Natural History I grew up outside of
New York great Museum of course Holden
Caulfield's favorite museum from The
Catcher in the Rye he used to love to
see the Indian the boat who never moved
but we never got to go to the Hayden
Planetarium which is right next door
part of the American Museum of Natural
History and in fact I had never been to
that planetarium until somewhat in the
mid 70s I suppose the planetarium
finally got hip and they decided to
start showing midnight movie Midnight
Star shows to the music of Pink Floyd
and by that point we were far less
interested in the constellations than we
were in other things and so we were
laying back there looking up at the
stars with Pink Floyd in the back in the
background and and I suppose my
attention was not exactly focused on
sorting out the difference between the
Big Dipper and the Little Dipper which
by the way are not constellations this
was one of the little surprises to me
the non-status of science student
they're not constellations but asterisms
and asterism is a small grouping of
stars within the much larger grouping of
stars known as a constellation so there
are always surprises when we start to
learn these things that we think we know
so as a nation indeed we are
astronomically ignorant in every sense
of the expression textbooks written by
one set of academics or professionals or
professors usually to be read by another
set of professors or academics rather
than the envy and user the reader are
largely to blame miss education media
confusion many many more people think
they know about what's out in space
because of Star Trek and Star Wars and
the x-files I love them all I love
science fiction I have from from the
time I was a kid but it's a dangerous
way to learn science
unfortunately the guys who tell the best
stories write science fiction and the
guys who know most about science write
textbooks and so in a way I suppose I'm
hoping that don't know much about the
universe will basically bridge that gap
between the science fiction stories
which are so good and the science which
is so good but somehow never the twain
shall meet
but what's really surprising to me most
about our failure in science education
our failure in history education is the
fact of how we teach these things often
it's a long list of dates and battles
and speeches or memorizing the names of
the planets and they leave out what is
essential that it's a human story and if
there's one thing I try and do in they
don't know much about Ceres is make this
a human story science got started when
people looked at the Sun the moon and
the stars and began to ask questions
where did the Sun go each night why the
stars move so predictably across the sky
why the Moon come and go and move in
such a regular way what did the moon and
the tides have to do with each other
because the Greeks figured that out a
long time ago and what did that have to
do with women their cycles of fertility
indeed they did start to ask that
question a long long time ago but from
all these very basic human questions
come all the complexities of mathematics
astronomy the calendar along with all
the myths and legends of human
civilization that's why I don't know
much about the universe is not just
about how far it is and what a black
hole is it's really about the human
quest for knowledge the human quest for
curiosity for understanding the universe
it begins about 5,000 years ago with a
group in the Mesopotamia area the
Sumerians they were the first people to
look at the Stars and begin to ask
questions and begin to chart the heavens
and they were the first to come up with
those pictures
so they invented the zodiac they were
also the group that invented writing the
wheel beer they also came up with the
idea based on looking at the sky of the
calendar and they invented the seven-day
week so it's fair to say that the
Sumerians gave us astrology beer and The
Weeknd so probably some time ago
5,000 years ago somebody in a local
Sumerian bar stopped up to somebody and
asked what's your sign but again that
shows that this is a very old human
story it's not just about getting all
the facts right it's understanding the
deeper connections and the deeper
connections between myth and
superstition and religion because indeed
the cosmologists the guy who the guys
who really and women who really think
about questions that can begin to hurt
your hair are asking the same questions
that the Sumerians were asking and the
Greeks were asking thousands and
thousands of years ago so there has been
this fashion fascination with with with
the heavens fascination with how they
move unfortunately that fascination can
mix with bad science occasionally with
tragic consequences it wasn't long ago
you probably all remember in March 1997
members of the California cult called
Heaven's Gate they were convinced by
their leader that they were aliens
trapped here on earth in an earth body
when they were going to leave those
earthly bodies someday the tipping point
for this cult came with the appearance
of the hale-bopp comet they were told
that the tail of that comet concealed an
alien mothership that was coming to take
them all away so a group of 39 people
committed mass suicide in a very sad
sacrifice to what I call pseudoscience
but this fascination is clearly what is
behind the deep love we all have for
science fiction whether it's dread or
delight the War of the Worlds I was just
reading once again about Orson Welles
taking the war the
in 1938 and transforming it into a radio
presentation they announced at the
beginning of the show that it was a
drama but then did not interrupt for the
next 40 minutes or so as they talked
about a meteor landing in Princeton New
Jersey a Princeton New Jersey and space
beings coming out and policemen being
killed and there was a true panic across
the country on the eve of Halloween in
1938 as Orson Welles spun this
extraordinary drama on live radio
frightful to think these days what such
a moment of fear and panic could do to
us again but we do love these things
Apollo 13 Armageddon Close Encounters of
the Third Kind et the remarkable legend
of star wars that has mystified and
beguiled an entire generation of
children we all learn yearn to go where
no man has gone before
the final frontier as my childhood
favorite Star Trek used to put it so it
really is a wonder that most of us are
so ignorant when it comes to the most
basic facts about the heavens lots of
people think that a white dwarf is one
of Snow White's little friends that Nova
goes great on bagels that black holes
have something to do with Calcutta but
this confusion doesn't mean that people
don't care it simply means that the
education system and the media have done
a lousy job of turning something that is
exciting and human and fascinating into
this exercise in tedium that we all
associate with learning about science
the universe astronomy or a whole range
of other subjects the good news is that
it's never too late I think to fill in
those black holes in our education and
don't know much about the universe sets
out to examine this subject about which
there is tremendous and popular
misconception but even greater public
fascination it addresses some of the
gaps in knowledge by looking skyward and
at
seeing what's out there now a very
typical reaction to people who here I've
written this book as they see wow what a
huge subject I mean thank you the whole
universe in one book well there's no
doubt about it taking on the universe is
a daunting task of rather cosmic
proportions the numbers become boggling
I mean just considering the vastness of
the universe does as I said about the
cosmologists it starts to hurt your hair
people are actually afraid they've said
to me I get nervous I get really nervous
thinking about these numbers I was
thinking the other day about the great
scene in Woody Allen's Annie Hall where
as a five-year-old boy he's taken into
his to see his doctor by his worried
mother doctor doctor he's worried the
universe is going to end and ensure the
the little five-year-old says it's true
I've read it regarde the universe is
going to end in five billion years there
is that anxiety that people have when it
comes to the subject I don't think we
have to worry about the next five
billion years for ourselves but there
are hundreds of billions of galaxies
each containing billions upon billions
of stars
how can you contain something that is
really touches the infinite and put it
into one simple accessible and ideally
entertaining book
well after writing a book about the
Bible taking on the universe is a rather
simple task it seems to me because for
most of the last two thousand years
people have gone been going to war over
the Bible
it's a divinely inspired inspired book
about faith tradition and law that has
been responsible for a good deal of the
blood spilled in the Western world so
with its competing interpretations and
millions of passionate readers the Bible
really represented a minefield of
controversy for me taking on the
vastness of space actually has a
reassuring quality of course there are
scientists who do argue over theories of
the beginnings of the universe but no
one's actually killed anyone yet over a
competing theory of the universe
although I suppose you could make a case
that Giordano Bruno was probably killed
for his ideas about the universe he was
a judge of Dominican priest he lived
around the time of Galileo he was a
contemporary of Galileo he was Italian
as Galileo was I never heard of Giordano
Bruno until I did the research for this
book in many ways he's even more
interesting than Galileo who for reasons
I'll explain I call the Al Gore of the
Renaissance
he had habit of taking credit for things
he didn't do but at any rate Giordano
Bruno before Galileo suggested it said
that the earth indeed was not the center
of the universe as Copernicus hat had
said about a hundred years earlier and
that the Sun was Bruna went a step
further he said that there are many
other worlds infinite worlds out there
which for him was essentially a really
good guess he had nothing to base that
on he had no telescope yet he was about
ten years too early this was just for
him a belief that in the vastness of the
universe when he looked at the stars in
the sky he knew that there was something
more there well his ideas about the
universe as well as his some of his
other ideas about religion and theology
and the fact that he had spilled some of
the secrets of the church in a book he
had written about in that time made him
not very popular with the Vatican and of
course this was the time of the
Reformation
so the Vatican was treating people who
didn't agree with them in very strict
ways Bruno for his heresies about
thinking about the universe was thrown
into prison for seven years he was told
to recant he refused he finally had his
palette pierced with a spike another
spike pushed through his lips he was
stripped naked paraded through the
streets of Rome
still being asked to recant I don't know
it seems a little difficult to me that
you could recant with a spike through
your palate but needless to say he did
not recant and he ended up being burned
on this at the stake in February of 1600
a true martyr to science and questioning
authority in questioning these easy
assumptions that we all sometimes hold
needless to say Galileo must have taken
note of what was going on with Bruno and
although he considered a Bruno Bruno a
kind of a fringe radical lunatic priest
it certainly must have had a chilling
effect on Galileo and indeed Galla
loaded did not publish some of his own
writings about the universe for another
11 or 13 years and even when he did
publish them it was with the approval of
the Vatican censors it was only when a
priest another priest jealous of attica
of a Galileo because Galileo had taken
credit for seeing sunspots first which
the priest said he had seen first this
is why this is a human story I say and
not just a story about Galileo figuring
out these great laws of the universe
this priest went to the Pope and said
you know that dialogue that Galileo
wrote well there's a character in there
whose support was a simpleton
his name is simplest that characters
modelled on you your eminence
and that's when Galileo got into trouble
because his book had been approved
already by the Vatican censors again
these are the little bits of history
that get left out of the science books
and the history textbooks but they make
it come to life they make it real
exciting interesting and I hope
something that we remember long past the
blue book review for the SATs one of the
reasons I did choose this subject is
that just as in Galileo's time when they
had the first telescopes which Galileo
did not invent he improved upon a Dutch
design and then sold it for a lot of
money to the Doge of Venice who thought
it would be useful to be able to see
armies coming a couple of hours in
advance or ships coming into Harbor a
few hours in advance so Commerce and
science always go together
we forget that fact as well Galileo made
a lot of money when he hooked up
a compass to the to a cannon and put it
alongside a an instrument that could
also measure angles so commerce and
defense spending have always been part
of science as well and that's what made
Galileo a very wealthy man in his day
but just as Galileo's zero wasn't the
opening of a tremendous exciting era of
discovery because of the telescope we
have been in the most one of the most
exciting periods in the history of space
exploration during the past ten years
the hubble space telescope the
deep-space probes advancing advances in
physics all of these developments have
sometimes confirmed and sometimes
altered very long-held ideas about the
universe at a 1999 lecture I heard that
a Hayden Planetarium I was told that
half of everything written about
astronomy and the universe has been
written in the last 10 years that's um
an extraordinary idea but apparently it
is the case and much of that has altered
very accepted basic wisdom that has been
taught for centuries in other words if
you were lucky to learn about astronomy
as I was not 20 or 30 years ago they've
written the books one glaring example
did you think there were nine planets
well not so fast they've demanded a
recount in space Pluto I always learned
my very excellent mother just served us
nine pizzas but Pluto has become
something in the Rodney Dangerfield of
the solar system it gets no respect some
astronomers have said it's not big
enough to be a planet they include the
Hayden Planetarium the Rose Center for
space and science in New York
not all astronomers agree but this is a
sort of tempest in a cosmic teapot right
now is Pluto a ninth the ninth planet or
is it a Kuiper belt object did you grow
up learning about three forms of matter
well now we know there are four forms of
matter the Sun is composed of not just a
gasps but something called plasma this
is not to avoid a confusion this is not
the plasma that is um the liquid portion
of your blood but this is a highly
ionized highly charged form of gas that
actually becomes a separate form of
matter so throw out most of the things
they talk to you 30 or 40 or even 20
years ago and you thought learning new
math was a pain why does it matter
especially right now I think that space
and the cosmos are sure to become a
bigger part of our lives and the debate
over how we explore it is an important
public question that demands information
we have obviously reached a day when the
science fiction fantasies of arthur c
clarke are now reality when that
beautiful spinning ferris wheel of a
space station was depicted in 2001 it
seemed impossible now we do have a space
station orbiting a few hundred miles
above earth it doesn't look like Arthur
C Clarke's but nonetheless we've come a
long way in a short period of time the
Soviet Union no longer exists but the
Russians have figured out a way how to
make a buck off that space station
they've beaten us at our own game they
got 20 million bucks from a guy named
Dennis Tito a former ask NASA engineer
who then went on to make a lot of money
in the stock market and they sent him to
space
they also got a million bucks from Pizza
Hut to deliver the first pizza to the
International Space Station there hasn't
even been the suggestion of a survivor
type reality television show set in an
astronaut training center with the
winner flying to the space station
former astronaut Buzz Aldrin who was the
second man on the moon has formed a
group to encourage space tourism in the
next decade so folks if not for us
certainly for our children and our
children's children space is going to be
a reality on a far more serious note I
think obviously the nation in the world
are concerned and we have been concerned
it's been pushed to the backburner a bit
about the anti-ballistic missile treaty
the Strategic Defense Initiative the
so-called Star Wars system we are
thinking about spending billions of
dollars on a technically questionable
venture that will affect our pocketbooks
and international relations in other
words thinking about space is not just
the exclusive turf of science fiction
writers and whiz kids with pocket
protectors who used to play in the
backyard with rockets instead of
baseballs
to that end don't know much about the
universe is aimed at providing some very
basic information about guiding us all
through the myths and misconceptions the
confusions about space white dwarfs
black holes dark matter
Nova's nebulae quasars and pulsars
asteroids comets meteors these are just
a handful of what I think are
fascinating celestial mysteries that
this book will cover as it seeks to
answer very old questions how did we get
here what are those lights where they
come from where are we going and I try
and link the present to the past so that
we see that those very questions that
were asked 3,000 years ago are the
questions we are still asking but I also
asked some other kind of different
questions as I mentioned that you won't
find in many other science books what
does astronomy have to do with astrology
more than half the people in this
country believe in astrology did
extraterrestrials build the pyramids who
dug those canals on Mars is the Blue
Moon really blue was Verna von Braun a
war criminal
do we end with a bang or a whimper these
questions are meant to spark the
imagination and get readers listening
and thinking in new ways questioning the
easy assumptions that so many of us hold
and that's what links don't know much
about the universe to all my other books
I hope to get people to question all the
easy assumptions they have and
underlying that they don't know much
about series is the idea that learning
should be a lot more interesting than it
was from
most of us education is not the filling
of a pail but the lighting of a fire
William Butler Yeats once said that and
that's sort of become the unofficial
motto of this series I think that
learning works best when we throw out a
subject throw out the old way of
teaching one subject at a time I went to
school and we learned English in first
period math and second history and third
science and fourth never any connection
when we make those connections when we
see the connections between geography
and history between learning about the
Bible and learning about the universe
they become a lot more interesting they
become a lot more compelling and that's
certainly the idea behind the don't know
much about series it's one thing to know
that a astrolabe is a middle leave
medieval device that was used to compute
the location of stars it's another thing
to learn that Geoffrey Chaucer of the
Canterbury Tales once wrote a how-to
manual of how to build an astrolabe I
didn't know that Galileo and Einstein
had illegitimate children both born out
of wedlock one of whom is of course the
subject of a best-selling book these
aren't sort of People magazine tidbits
meant to sully their reputation
instead I hope it shows that these were
real people real human beings which
makes their accomplished accomplishments
all the more remarkable so seeing how
people make a difference in history
understanding the connections between
everyday life and historical events
ultimately makes these subjects a lot
more compelling and interesting when you
see Galileo as a proud egotistical
certainly a genius but who certainly
also took credit for things that other
did if other people did as I mentioned
the Algor of the Renaissance
he becomes a lot more interesting so
apart from answering some of these
questions and certainly helping parents
through the mine fields of science
homework along the way beyond the
practical application this book is aimed
at allowing all of us to share in that
age-old human wonder about the skies
when you are through I hope you'll be
able to look up with a little bit more
understanding and appreciation instead
of a blank stare and see that in the pop
words of Walt Whitman every inch of
space is a miracle thank you very much
now I've been talking so much about
questions what I really would like to do
is take some of your questions if you
have them not only about don't know much
about the universe but about any and all
of my books and I've just been asked
that if you would like to offer up a
question that you use the microphone at
the the begin at the entrance of the
podium here please come on down if one
or two of more of you want to come down
we can make a line we only have the room
for a few more minutes so maybe we can
facilitate this by having a few people
step on down hello I can hear you if and
I'll repeat the question if everyone can
fit into mnemonics lately my very
excellent
what served us nine pizzas let's all say
it together children my very excellent
mother just served us nine pizzas my
very excellent mother just served us
nine pizzas I'm so glad that was the
first question instead of you know one
of those what is really the edge of
infinity you know that's usually the
first question I get our I get that with
one minute to go on a televisions
interview and you know I'm sitting there
and we've just been talking about the
book and they say well now really how
will the universe end you know in 30
seconds so my very excellent mother just
served us nine pizzas is what they
taught taught us back in elementary
school so at least I remembered one
thing but now you know the pizzas may be
out the window so Mar Mercury Venus
Earth Mars Jupiter Saturn Uranus Neptune
and Pluto ha isn't that impressive yes
sir new book delve into the
multi-universe aspect of the quantum
theory see that's the kind of question I
didn't want
does my new book delve into the
multi-universe theory of quantum theory
yes it does
the I break it down very briefly for you
the first section of the book is a
history of astronomy more or less how
men and women and humanity have looked
at space from the very beginning
beginning of time basically through the
time of Newton and then I move on to a
sort of field trip through the solar
system so that you will all be
comfortable talking about our nearest
neighbors then I move on to an overview
of everything else that's out there
galaxies mostly about stars and what
we've learned about stars in the last
ten years or so then a quick overview of
the space program itself how we went
from in this century thinking about this
to doing it in a very very short period
of time it's an extraordinary story when
you think that in less than a century we
went from science fiction to landing on
the moon the final section deals with
what I call the big questions and
certainly that is one of them just to
introduce the notion for some folks here
cosmologists the physicists the
mathematicians who are working at a very
high level of theoretical mathematics
don't know how this universe will end
don't know where this universe is going
have begun to question if there are
other universes the most popular among
those theories right now and I think
understood by about 12 people
Einstein once said that on there were
only 12 people in the world who
understood what he was saying he later
turned out he never said such a thing
but I think it can probably be applied
in this case to string theory and
quantum theory there are about 12 people
in the world who understand it but it
does posit that the universe might be
very different from the way we think
about it string theory too very overly
vastly simplify it says that the the
universe is composed of very very
rapidly vibrating strings of energy
which could contain whole universes and
that the structure of the universe could
be what we think of tend to think of
most of us think of it as just this flat
thing going out it's also been been
compared to being inside a raisin bread
as it's being baked and you know it
starts to rise and all the raisins which
are the galaxies are all separating and
moving apart from each other the
question is what happens does that
expansion does the raisin bread keep
rising indefinitely does it stop
does it collapse back in on itself
what's on the other side of that
universe obviously all of these are in
the realm of speculation and highly
highly theoretical physics we don't know
that yet we don't know that although in
the next 10 years we're probably going
to have many many more answers to those
questions so the brief answer is yes my
book does come and it does cover that
I'm not sure how much more there is to
say about it beyond which there are
fascinating ideas and new discoveries
that have absolutely reshaped this there
was about one month ago an article in
the front page of the New York Times
that essentially said some physicists
had come up theoretically with the idea
that the whole speed of the universe
that we'd been thinking about for a long
time is way off if they are correct it
really challenges the whole foundation
of modern cosmology modern physics so
we're we're kind of right now at a
wait-and-see attitude if anybody's still
nervous about that we still have you
know plenty of time to figure this out
as I said
we have we have about six billion years
left on our Sun so we don't have to
worry about that event happening
imminently and the question of how much
longer this universe goes on is one that
the theologia theologists can argue
about with the cosmologists but that is
the interesting intersection that we
reach in the end of don't know much
about the universe because now we have
the scientists talking about what the
theologist the theologians only used to
talk about
it's that intersection between faith and
reason science and religion that I find
so fascinating thank you please your
subjects are so broad how do you begin
to structure your research when you're
getting started how do you how do you
tackle it my subjects are so broad how
do I attack them well as Michael said
when he introduced me I consider myself
a very average person and I think that
if I'm interested in something a lot of
other people will be interested in it
but it basically comes down to two
things curiosity and sort of what I call
household word approach we all have
these words whether it's in the field of
astronomy or American history or
geography or the Bible we have these
words and phrases and people and events
that we all recall as being important
but we can't always put our finger on
exactly why so the first thing I do is
really look for those household words
whether it's black hole in don't know
much about the universe or manifest
destiny in talking about American
history and if you can find a way to
talk about those those terms those
phrases in a way that's accessible means
something to people today and not just a
phrase that relates back to what
happened 200 years ago or is only of
interest to a few scientists I think
that's when you connect with the average
person's curiosity I've found in the
past 10 years and 11 years that I've
been doing these books and traveling
around the country and speaking to
people in sessions like this or on the
raid
that there is enormous appetite for
learning people want to know they want
to learn they want to understand but
they certainly wanted in a style of
format that's a lot more appealing than
the way most of us got it back in high
school I can't tell you how many
teachers people have said to me they
learned history from the football coach
I hope there are no football coaches who
teach American history here today but
I've heard that story so many times it
was not the case in in my education but
I've heard it often enough to think well
gee there might be a pattern here there
might be a problem that a guy who you
know needed something teaches football
but needs something else to kind of
occupy his day well they put them in the
history class maybe that's the way it
works in some parts of the country I
don't know but but we need to keep
learning and I think that just answering
these questions in a way that is a
little offbeat and fun and entertaining
it's not for everyone my books are not
considered you know Pulitzer Prize
material add that's ok as long as I keep
getting letters from kids who say I
hated history until I read your book and
I don't now a real or a parent who says
we took a trip and we listened to your
book about American history on our honor
on the road and really allowed us to
talk about the places we've been this is
partly a book these are books about
starting conversations they are not the
last word on these subjects sometimes
they're the first word and then I want
you to go out and keep finding out more
I'll try and give you the basic tools
and the basic information so you can
have an intelligent conversation about
these things but there's a big
difference between the subtitle says
everything you need to know and
everything there is to know it's a
somewhat subjective idea and I'm sure
there are people who think I've left
very important things out of some of my
books but for the main I just try and
cover the basic basis and I'll tell you
a dirty little secret sometimes I find
the answers and then I write the
questions because I will
discover something that I didn't know
about or hadn't been thinking about in
my research that's the beauty of
research one of my favorite examples of
that is when I was writing don't know
much about geography I was looking for a
book about Columbus one of those
serendipitous moments I went to the
library reached for the book that I
wanted and two books across which is why
I go to libraries and I used the
internet a lot but I still go to the
library is that serendipity I found the
logs of Christopher Columbus the actual
notes he had made as the captain of the
ship in his log he wrote about being off
the coast of South America this was now
his third voyage and he writes about a
river running out into the ocean he
thinks of course he's still off the
coast of China somewhere somewhere
around Asia well he writes that this
river is in fact the river mentioned in
the book of Genesis and he has
discovered Eden this is funny nobody
ever told me that Columbus thought he
found the Garden of Eden but indeed he
had he takes it a little step further he
says this is a very high place on the
earth and so his whole view of the earth
had changed the world is not round he
wrote but pear-shaped I took back
another step back wait a second they
always told us Columbus proved around
what world was round now he's writing in
his log that the world isn't round then
he goes one step further the world is
not round but pear-shaped shaped like a
woman's breasts and this part is the
nipple the highest and part closest to
heaven and I really step back and said
wow they never told me that back in
seventh grade I'm sure I would have
taken notes I don't know maybe a sail or
two long at sea but but the point is
that I didn't go I didn't go looking to
answer the question did Columbus really
think the world was round but it was one
of those serendipitous aha Eureka
moments that I so often come across in
my research and that is one of the
reasons I do my own research I there is
not you know a stable of 100 little
assistants scurrying around I have the
luxury of working on these books and
these books alone
I don't have to teach or wait tables or
drive a cab as so many other writers
have to do to earn a living so I have
the luxury of working on each of these
books for about three years and fairly
intensively cramming and I guess what
would be you know a couple of years of
graduate school worth of research and
study in a very short space of time so
that's my basic approach and then that
the trick is always to find a way to
make it a little bit more fun the
information is out there this stuff is
in all these books people have spent
their lives finding the stuff and trying
to tell us about it some of them are not
so good at telling us about so I try and
be you know the guy who finds all the
interesting stuff and then pass it along
to you another question sir yes sir you
talked about writing and perhaps
popularizing science in some way and we
we all know that in this country science
and schools is being under taught Carl
Sagan was one of those people who also
popularize science do you see another
Carl Sagan out there somewhere someone
who can make science entertaining gee
let me think about that is there
somebody out there who can make
astronomy entertaining I'll have to
think about that awhile I think there
are a lot of really good writers in the
science field Carl Sagan was a singular
person and he had this extraordinary
showman's ability and being a good
teacher is sometimes being a bit of a
showman I've always thought that
teaching was you know partly theatre
partly stand-up comedy and partly really
know what knowing what you're talking
about and the best teachers and I always
believed that the reason you really
learn something is school in school is
because you have a great teacher I think
so it's partly finding a great teacher
and a great showman and a stand-up comic
Sagan had that ability there are
certainly very very good science writers
I think the success of books like Davis
o bells book on longitude for instance
and she also wrote the book about
Galileo's daughter the success of those
books proved that there is an interest
there is a fascination part of the
problem is always with I mean Carl Sagan
was successful because he had wonderful
support from public television public
televisions in a lot of trouble these
days so they're not putting together 20
episodes shows on the cosmos so there
are a lot of a lot of complications I'm
not dancing around your question in the
sense that I don't know of any one
particular person who would be the next
Carl Sagan
but if PBS is watching I'm free I'm
available but but I do think that there
are a lot of incredibly talented people
at a national level but also in the
schools you know I have tremendous I've
been sort of railing against education
and how bad it is but teachers are in
there they are the grunts in this war
and we give them very poor weapons to
fight this war we have tremendous
expectations we want them to teach
reading and writing and rithmetic now we
want them to teach morality and
character and and religion as well at
the same time that we're paying them
wages that wouldn't keep most of us
comfortable and happy so I think that at
the grass roots at the bottom that's the
really important place it's going to
happen if there's another Carl Sagan
that comes along that can really excite
the imagination I think that that does
happen maybe it's maybe his name is you
know George Lucas and maybe he's doing
that in a way for this generation of
kids that's growing up on this wonderful
myth and magic of Star Wars but the
trick is then to take the Star Wars and
translate it into real science over
there yes I was just wondering what was
your favorite book you wrote or the one
you had
fun writing the favorite of my own books
that I've written and which I've had the
most fun writing would you ask me which
of my children I love best hmm no I mean
I'm often asked that and it does feel -
I do have two lovely children and I
could never choose between them but
unfortunately my books while I think of
them as children aren't really children
I really like all these subjects and
I've enjoyed working on all these
subjects and if the books have been
successful over the last 10 or 12 years
I think it probably comes out of the
idea that this is my personal enthusiasm
for these subjects I don't write about
things that I don't really care about
that is why you won't see don't know
much about the the stock market most
likely there won't be a you know don't
know much about quantum physics it's
it's interesting to me but I folded it
into this one
there won't be don't know much about
small engine repair I really like these
subjects and I try and bring my own
curiosity and enthusiasm to the books
and I think that that's what may come
across but if you really press me hard
American history is probably my first
real love and it's the first book in the
series
it remains to date the most successful
book in this series it is the book that
actually I'm in the midst of a complete
revision update expansion because it is
about 12 years since it was written and
my goal is to write essentially a new
version of that that will certainly
cover events the last 15 years or so we
had a little thing in there called the
end of communism for instance that I
thought should be addressed and also
we've learned a lot about the past
everything from Jefferson's DNA to
discovering the fort at Jamestown that's
reshaping our views about the past I
probably only have another minute or two
because the crowds are pounding at the
door so maybe this will be our last
question
who's extremely interested in in space
and would this be the book that I should
read so I can talk to this brilliant
child well yes you could read this book
to talk to him and you can also by don't
know much about the solar system which
is a picture book for five-year-olds see
we're covering all the demographic bases
now marketing marketing marketing no
I've actually just begun writing books
for children this is sort of a lifelong
dream when my own children were growing
up I didn't think there was there were
wonderful picture books and wonderful
storybooks but I didn't think there was
enough good nonfiction for children so
I've brought that don't know much about
idea having fun jokes riddles questions
and brought them down for for children
but certainly you could read this book
and he could read that book and then you
could have a really interesting
conversation together so thank you very
much and thank you all for coming I
appreciate very much I need to mention
before we all leave that Kenneth will be
signing and the signing colonnade which
is on legislative Plaza
we're walking over there right now if
you want to go Thanks